so I'm Marcia Cassini and I'm a
professor at MIT I'm also an affiliate
of the vector Institute uh and
University of Toronto and today I'm
going to talk to you about the pulse of
ethical machine learning and health and
I should warn you I had a talk that is a
tight hour I I had it all I've given it
50 times and this is a brand new talk so
you are either blessed or cursed with
being the uh the first people to hear
this particular set of uh of slides
so um my group at MIT is the healthy
machine learning lab and we try to
create actionable insights in human
health
and here's a case study of what you
might do if you're working in machine
learning and health so let's say that
you uh have a patient who comes into the
hospital Simone is having trouble
breathing she goes to the emergency room
they do a chest x-ray but the doctor
can't look at the chest x-ray for two
hours because there are lots of people
in the emergency room but if she's
healthy she would really like to just go
home can we build a model to triage her
well uh if we wanted to focus on this
there is a pipeline that we work with in
machine learning generally where we
select a problem identify data collect
an outcome label uh develop an algorithm
and then finally look at post-deployment
considerations for our model and we've
already done the first one right we know
we want to develop this triage system
for chest X-rays and so let's try to do
the rest of these steps we're going to
take the three largest test x-ray data
sets that's over 700 000 images of chest
X phrases our data we're going to create
a finding of no finding for our label
right so that means if there's a bunch
of different things that you could have
diagnosed from the chest x-ray and I
want to predict if you're healthy and
you can go home the label I should use
is no finding I'm going to train a
densnet which is a kind of convolutional
neural network that's the algorithm I'm
going to optimize and then once I'm done
I'm going to look at my performance
right and so we find in this paper that
we're able to create state-of-the-art
performance on this specific task this
is great we've gone through this
development pipeline but it's not just
us who have gone through this
development pipeline this paper is a few
years old now but it was identifying
that there are now a range of tasks that
AI can do at or above humans across
different uh spans of human tasks right
so anything from tasks that are done to
on very young to very old people we now
have ai that performs really really well
and so we've achieved that sort of check
mark of it has very high performance
um what if we got through all of these
steps like I just told you with uh the
model we have and now we want to
consider deploying it in the same
emergency room well that's okay too uh
so in the US we have the FDA and there's
different regulatory bodies in Canada
and in Europe and what happens is these
Regulatory Agencies essentially look at
your model and they audit it the way
that you would do for a drug for example
looking at performance
um in different settings and then they
clear it to be released this is a
website that tracks every uh AI system
that's been released by the FDA approved
by the FDA
um and so you can see that there are
hundreds of these across different kinds
of settings that have already been
approved for deployment
so now the question is let's go back to
my case study so she's having trouble
breathing she has this chest x-ray and
they offer her you can wait two hours
for a chest x-ray to be reviewed by
clinician or we could have ai triage you
right now
so the question is what should sumana
choose
what would you choose so hands up if you
would choose to be triaged by the AI
right now no waiting time
okay some people hands up if you would
choose the doctor for two hours
more people skeptical crowd wow is this
a summer school for AI
and in the wrong room
um so maybe a reason you wouldn't choose
the AI is he's had a bad experience in
the medical system recently so I live in
Massachusetts there was a paper that
came out in the New England Journal uh
this past month actually looking at the
admissions that have happened at 11
Massachusetts hospitals they found that
at least one adverse event occurred in
over 20 percent of admissions due to uh
the provider's error so a doctor a
clinical staff member made a mistake of
those more than 20 percent were judged
to be preventable and over 30 percent
had a severity level of serious or
higher that's just in one state with
some random samples and looking over
this past year but what that means is
the federal agency in the United States
Air HQ that's responsible for looking at
these kinds of mistakes and their impact
on Americans estimates that there are
7.4 million U.S emergency department
patients that are misdiagnosed and 2.6
million that suffer an adverse event as
a result
and so the question is that's the data
we're using
to train this model where else would we
get it from how well do we think this
model will perform on a patient like
sumana do we think it makes similar
mistakes on all kinds of people
and you might say there are other
sources of data that we could use that
would maybe supplement this so that we
don't make serious mistakes for example
we have randomized controlled trials but
randomized control trials are actually
very rare I don't know if you knew this
but very few treatments are based on
them because they're expensive and
they're hard to do one of the reasons
they're hard to do is because you have
to create a population where you can
only study the effect of a specific
intervention on an outcome and that
means that your recruited population is
necessarily extremely narrow and so my
favorite statistic is 94 of asthmatics
would have been ineligible for the
treatment RCT that was used to design
their treatment
even worse what will happen sometimes is
there will be a medical reversal so top
uh journals in medicine like Lancia
Gemma New England Journal will publish a
paper saying the thing that we thought
was a good Medical Practice actually
that's bad and we should not do that
anymore
What If instead we look at this from the
provider's practice point of view so
what happens when you actually go to the
doctor if there's not a randomized
control trial on your specific condition
and specific drugs they probably are
going to look at what has worked for
other people like you in the past right
so doctors will think uh I know that
patients have generally reacted to this
medication well so what would happen if
we took a data set of 250 million
patients
and then looked at the treatments they
got just the medications and then tried
to identify how many patients followed a
completely unique treatment pathway that
means they have zero nearest Neighbors
in this data set for common conditions
like diabetes depression and
hypertension for diabetes it's 10 for
depression is 11 and almost a quarter of
hypertensive patients if you ask the
question what treatment should you get
next according to your nearest neighbor
the answer would be I don't know because
there are zero nearest Neighbors in this
data set of 250 million people
in order to move forward with AI and
health we need to think really carefully
about how these kinds of factors are
going to affect the model that we create
so let's go back and look at this model
that we trained that we were very proud
of that we have a paper nature medicine
about just like all those other papers
let's look at the false positive rate of
this model false positives because if
you falsely positively predict that
somebody is healthy that's under
diagnosis and let's compare that in
different subpopulations because if you
falsely positively say that more women
are healthy when they're actually sick
that would lead to under diagnosis in
female patients for example and when we
run this audit on our state-of-the-art
model that you know looks great on
average and could be cleared by the FDA
we find that it has the largest under
diagnosis rate in female patients young
patients black patients and patients on
public insurance
and your underperformance is actually
worse in intersectional identities so
that means if you're a Black Or Hispanic
female patient in the United States you
have a higher under diagnosis rate than
white female patients and uh then your
aggregated group of just female patients
this is not just true in imaging data
right so I used to have to when I was
talking about this paper say oh there
are these things called contextual
language models and I don't have to do
that anymore all I have to do is say you
all have heard of language models right
uh so if we do clinical note completion
which is a task that uh actually epic
which is a big EHR provider in the
United States and Canada now
um has in many Hospital Systems uh
they've integrated the gpt4 add-on in
some hospitals where if you're typing a
node in Epic you can use the gpt4 plugin
to complete a patient's note super
helpful right taking notes takes a long
time so if I uh start this sentence from
a real patient's note from a Boston area
hospital with Caucasian or white patient
became belligerent and violent cyber
completes this note with they were sent
to hospital if I started with African
African-American our black patient
became belligerent and violent cyber
completes this with they were sent to
prison
so this is not just a bias that's found
in imaging data and it's not a bias that
is easily removed it's something that is
very deeply seated because guess what
humans are biased and so the way that we
provide care is sometimes explicitly and
implicitly biased and that shows up in
the data that we are using okay
so this is not something that we can do
you know simply it's an ongoing process
that's going to require diverse data and
teams
um I'm going to go through some parts of
this pipeline not all of them because
that would take too long
um and the first one I want to talk
about is data and I want to talk about
data specifically in those two
modalities notes and imaging because you
might be wondering okay there are these
biases how bad can it be
this is a real note where I've redacted
the patient's self-reported race can you
tell the race of this patient probably
not because we tested doctors let me
tell you I have a bunch of friends from
when I was a graduate student that are
all doctors and they all hate me because
I test them all the time and they always
fail my tests which they're not used to
because they're very good doctors but
doctors cannot tell I promise you
whether this patient self-reports their
race as black or white why should they
well models can and models can in some
cases because they're using things that
maybe would consider Fair they're using
statistical biases not societal biases
so for example in the Northeast
African-American patients have a higher
rate of hypertension and a higher rate
of using dialysis okay that's fine
but it's not just things like that so we
looked at two cohorts in Boston and New
York and both very simple and higher
capacity models are able to predict your
self-reported race uh with very very
high performance and sometimes they're
using things that we probably don't want
them to be able to use like if you call
a patient or their family difficult that
patient is probably black not white
if you mention anything about the skin
presented illness of a patient
they are probably white and that's
because Dermatology textbooks actually
have almost no examples of the skin
related presentation of illness at all
on darker Skin So doctors don't know how
to diagnose if they don't know how to
notice it they don't know how to use it
at all so they just don't talk about
your skin
if you have darker skin
what about in images we can all imagine
how our implicit or explicit biases
might show up in a medical note right as
we're typing
um but this is a medical image right
it's a chest x-ray
surely there's nothing here and so also
I have a bunch of radiologist friends
who all hate me now
um Radiologists cannot tell from a chest
x-ray whether your self-reported race
not your genetic ancestry as one weird
eugenicist reviewer suggested your
self-reported race is black or white but
machine learning models can
they can do so with very very high
performance they can do so on multiple
sites they can do so even when we have
evenly distributed data sets so we
looked at Emory University where they
have an even distribution of black Mi
patients um and they can do so across a
variety of modalities
and if I uh asked the Radiologists okay
give me a list of every single Spirits
correlation or proxy or cheating you
know way that you think a neural network
could be uh sort of guessing at
somebody's self-reported race and I'll
test it it's not any of the ones we
tested it's not body mass index breast
density bone density or disease
distribution which was the one I thought
it would be in fact you can filter these
images if you're an ee person you can
Band cast filter these images until they
do not look like chest x-rays anymore
but even things that have a little more
than you know what we perceive as
spectral noise have extremely high
performance
and so this is not information that you
can easily remove from somebody's
medical record if you were looking at
somebody's notes if you were looking at
their medical images and you thought oh
well I've removed any mentions of
self-reported race from their EHR and so
my model won't be able to do the um uh
bias performance that you showed
it's very deeply proxied in medical data
is in way that we cannot detect
and so it's important if you decide to
work with Health Data that you recognize
both that data is a very powerful good
it's it's something that we need to
curate it's something that we need to
have available as researchers because if
we don't have diverse data sets for
research use what will happen is what's
happening right now namely uh hospitals
will sell data to companies companies
will create models like I showed you
they will be biased and we in academic
spaces will not have the capacity to
audit them because we don't have access
to the same data sets
and right now that is what's happening
so Health really lags other machine
learning subfields and reproducibility
as it stands and it's largely because
people do not release their
de-identified data under data usage
agreement there are some data sets that
the community uses but it's really
lacking in terms of what other
communities have been able to do
all right that's the first section
that's that's uh what happens with data
what about outcome definition surely
there's nothing sketchy going on here
any questions before I move on
uh-huh
uh so the question was do we know what
was happening with the Imaging data is
that correct uh there is no way to prove
it but uh some of our initial guesses
are that it's special information from
bounce back from x-rays when you have
more melanin
right like
waves actually interact with melanin and
so it's possible that that's it we can't
prove that we don't have photos of
people's skin we're assuming that
there's correlation between these things
okay
why is it called
I I think it's the differential
performance that's biased right so I
think there's no problem in a perfect
Society with a machine learning model
being able to detect your self-reported
race who cares right the fact that a
model could perfectly detect it and then
it could have some biased judgment that
is made as a result of it because it's
learning from other data that we treat
black patients this way we treat white
patients this way that's the issue it's
not a problem independently that you
could infer this I would say yes
so what we looked at is whether within a
specific subgroup there was a higher or
lower level of false positives within
the labels so um you're right that we
are looking at the ultimate diagnosis in
the medical records themselves as the
true label
um and as we'll go into in this section
maybe there are some reasons to be
skeptical about that but unfortunately
that's a lot of what we have to rely on
right now unless uh some of the data
sets that we used in that study they're
not just looking at the underlying label
um so I think checks for certainly uh
but also the NIH data set had
independent Radiologists review the
charts post-hoc and they had to concur
on the um the diagnosis in order to have
uh the label in the data set and so all
of the labels that we use in general and
machine learning have a specific issue
I'll go through but you're right that in
health there's an even further issue
that you could have two Radiologists
that each have a decade of training from
the best institution and they could look
at the same record and disagree about
the diagnosis that's fundamental
uncertainty that we can't address
um so for outcome definition getting
into some of these questions that we've
been asked
um this is how you might create an
outcome label for a specific task so my
kids school has a meal policy this is
true by the way uh they have a meal
policy that prohibits high sugar content
meals so if you bring a meal to school
it can't have high sugar content so
let's say that they want to build a
machine learning model that is helpful
where you can take a picture of your
meal and it'll classify like does this
meal prohibit is this meal prohibited
under the school policy so how would we
build this model we would take images
like this one of a breakfast I would
enjoy eating because I think it's Cocoa
Puffs and whipped cream and we would ask
a bunch of labelers does this have high
sugar content yes or no
and then we would train a machine
learning model to predict the majority
class right if most people say this has
high sugar content then we should
predict it has high sugar content
um that's sort of a standard way that we
do this in all machine learning tasks
but the problem is this is actually a
little bit different than the task we're
applying it to we're not just trying to
detect high sugar content usually when
we collect labels like this we're
applying it not to a descriptive setting
like describe this image we're applying
it to a normative setting like if this
is true make a social decision based on
it so what would have happened if we
would have asked people instead does
this meal violate a school meal policy
that prohibits high sugar content and
you might all be saying those are
exactly the same one is the if condition
one is the then condition right so it's
going to be approximately the same thing
but if you ask people the if condition
17 out of 20 say this is a high sugar
meal but only two out of 20 say that it
violates a school policy that prohibits
high sugar meals
and this is not just true in this meal
policy example it's true across a number
of settings where you might collect data
descriptively and then apply it
normatively so for example a dress code
for an office a meal policy for a school
a pet code for a building or Forum
guidelines about toxic comments right
and so in each of these settings we did
the same thing we collected data about
specific images or text samples both in
a normative and then a descriptive first
descriptive and normative setting on
different samples of people and then we
looked at what would happen if we
trained machine learning models as we
often do with a descriptive data and
applied it to the normative setting and
compared that to what would have
happened if you would have trained the
machine learning model on labels
collected from the normative setting in
the first place and what we find is that
models train the way that we train them
by default right now in machine learning
tend to be much harsher in their
judgments than if we would have trained
them on the data that simulates the
normative setting we were applying them
to so when we collect data about is this
high sugar and then apply it to does it
violate the policy of no high sugar we
have much harsher judgments than if we
would have told people the setting that
we were applying it to
and you can compare the difference the
impact the Gap this error to what would
have happened if you had higher very
high I would say rates of label noise
High rates of data sub sampling or just
used a much worse model so if you would
have used a uh better model Bert the in
uh in contrast to the Alberta model in
uh the toxic common classification case
the impact is a one percent difference
if you use the right data the
normatively collected data in the
normative setting the impact is 6.5
percent
so this is a very important problem
another thing that we do once we've
collected data and outcomes is try to
optimize our algorithms in ways that are
going to increase overall performance
before I go into some of the algorithm
development work any questions on
outcome definition
all right great
so how do we optimize models for health
settings well
what we could do is what happens right
now a lot of the time which is we have a
very large data set maybe that's held
privately by a hospital or a health
provider and they won't release their
data the data probably has some
asymmetry uh so the data set I'm
thinking of is the VA data set in the
United States that has more male
patients than female patients and
they'll train some sort of Upstream
embedding model some sort of
representation they're not going to
release the data so they just released
the representation right so they have
this latent embedding space now you
private hospitals separately can take
your own maybe more balanced perfectly
Fair data and train a downstream
classifier after you project to our
beautiful embedding space that we've
trained and released for you
so we found that the bias uh in data
that causes the sort of Upstream
asymmetric embeddings actually gets
propagated forward into Downstream tasks
even when you rebalance the training
data for the downstream task to be
perfectly fair so this is a big problem
that we deal with looking at the
difference between issues with the
representation that is learned versus
the classifier that could be trained on
top of that with potentially different
or better data moted by motivated by
this one of the things we've been
looking at is how do we use group
attributes in prediction so there's a
big question right now in the United
States in general in the medical
community about how and when we should
use group attributes like sex age and
self-reported race and clinical risk
scores so you can imagine the problem is
if we use group attributes it can result
in worse subgroup performance even
though it's improving the overall group
performance so in this example if we
train a logistic regression model to
predict sleep apnea with sex and age
it's worse for younger male and older
female patients and so they might have
preferred for example the less
demographically personalized model
because it's helping most people but not
them
and the reason that this happens in
general is because we either have
modelness specification where models are
unable to capture necessary interaction
effects between a feature and a group
attribute or during model selection when
we're doing hyper parameter optimization
often what we're doing is optimizing for
overall performance and that can result
in worse performance for a very specific
subgroup
so what should we do in these cases our
argument in this uh new paper appearing
next week at icml is that we should
really just audit and resolve issues of
fair use of demographic data as we are
doing case-specific usage in clinical
risk scores so for example here if I
wanted to predict a model uh if I wanted
to create a model to predict mortality
for acute kidney injury patients what I
would do first is look at what happens
when I have a group blind classifier H
naught look at the performance across
groups compare that to a decoupled per
group sort of more personalized
classifier and then compare that to what
happens when I use race as an input
predictor in addition to other
demographic features and here we find
that the this leads to worse performance
in the model across all metrics for
black men and so we would not recommend
that this is used in this specific
clinical risk score this is one example
we show many examples in the paper where
this is not true right so it depends
specifically on the data you have and
the outcome you're trying to predict no
one solution resolves all fair use
violations and so this is something you
have to run on a Case basis
um another thing that might be important
if you don't want to develop a clinical
risk score specifically because you
don't want
um sort of these more regression focused
tasks is a clinical checklist or
decision list
this is very very popular in medicine
because checklists are easy to use Easy
to deploy and easy to verify
unfortunately these checklists are
created by humans by a consensus of
humans and often what happens is you
spend lots and lots of time having
experts come together and try to Define
these checklists and then later a grade
paper like the the one below hidden in
plain sight will be written that says
you know all these checklists we have
they actually don't work very well for
uh specific subgroups of people
and so one of the things that we worked
on is actually learning and optimally
predictive checklist directly from data
using mixed integer programming the nice
thing about this is you get to have
constraints like a specific number of
items for example but you can also
include fairness restrictions why is
that important let's look at a case
study
um so let's say you want to predict
mortality after a specific treatment in
the ICU continuous renewal replacement
therapy it's an end-of-life treatment
it's painful and expensive you don't
want to give it if somebody will die
right after it okay but we also want to
ensure fairness across intersectional
patient groups because just like my
first example if you falsely positively
predict that one subgroup will always
die after this treatment it will lead to
them not getting care that would
actually benefit them okay so when we
train the first model with no fairness
restrictions we tested this on our ICU
colleagues they said that looks great
it's not using any positive proxies for
example one proxy that doctors know
about
um in um in medical data is biological
sex at Birth so uh female patients have
lower height lower weight on average
they said oh it's not using height and
weight so it's probably not biased
against uh those patients
um there are some lab tests like egfr
that have different ranges for patients
of different self-reported race it's not
using any of those so this should be a
fair model right
even though we didn't put any fairness
constraints in it but this checklist
actually has a max false positive rate
gap of over 50 between white men and
black women
so you would not have wanted to deploy
this model where is the proxy I don't
actually know
and neither do the doctors
and so it's important to always check
your models even if they look completely
fine right when we add In fairness
constraints we lose some overall
performance but we gain back fairness
within a range that is more tolerable
for a deployed ICU environment
the final thing I want to talk about is
shifts in algorithm development so
shifts are a big and robustness shifts
are a big issue in the machine learning
community in general but they're
particularly important in health because
many of the distributionally robust
optimization methods that are uh a very
wonderful perform extremely well in
other data settings really fail in
health tasks and further if you try to
use stable learning algorithms like
differential privacy as part of your
optimization what we found is that
differential privacy by default if
anybody Works in it noises and clips the
gradient effect for data points that are
outliers that's how you guarantee the
differential privacy of unique data
points who do you think is an outlier in
medical data
minorities yes so guess who gets noised
and clipped don't use differential
privacy and Health Data it's it's very
scary I have to say all right so what
can we do
can we actually learn underpopulation
shift and if so under which kinds of
population shift and so we look at four
different kinds various correlations
where attribute in class are hot on the
diagonal attribute imbalance where you
have more of a specific kind of
attribute throughout all classes class
imbalance and then also attribute
generalization where we just don't
observe any specific attribute class
pair and we have to try to generalize to
that shift
and uh we're in luck because actually
many of the default machine learning
data sets out there exhibit these
different kinds of shifts class and
balance and attribute and balance have a
lot of Health data sets in them uh so
this would be the chest x-ray multi-site
the mimic notes uh the checksport data
set the mimic cxr data set but a lot of
the other data sets that we use in
District distributionally robust
optimization paper benchmarking also
exhibit spurious correlation and
attribute generalization effects
and so what we find when we Benchmark
the top papers in this space on these
different tasks is that many of the
algorithms do indeed improve on spurious
correlation and class imbalance but even
really group like great models that
perform extremely well like dfr and CRT
in those two settings do not improve
attribute uh imbalance and attribute
generalization specifically
this is an issue uh that we tried to
decompose into again this relative
contribution between representations
that can be trained and classifiers that
can be trained so if we freeze a
representation and try to improve a
classifier we found that it's possible
that you can improve Spirits
correlations and class imbalance if you
improve the representation itself you
can have some small impact to the
attribute imbalance task but nothing
improves attribute generalization so
this is a very difficult task that is
present in a lot of healthcare settings
and it's something we need to develop
better models for
a final thing to note is uh almost every
single one of these papers they optimize
for worst group accuracy it's the gold
standard for subpopulation evaluation
but do you remember what we've been
going through in many of these examples
but the thing that we care more about is
it's this like false positive right like
you don't want to under diagnose people
so worse group accuracy is correlated
with things like adjusted accuracy but
it's actually inversely proportional to
worst group precision
so when you are training your models and
evaluating them for subgroups be very
careful which metrics you use because it
might actually
um be significantly worse for certain
populations and so it's possible if
you're doing a triage task Precision is
actually what you care about more than
anything
so how do we address some of these
shifts let's say that we have a big
Source domain hospital where we do
really well and then we notice that when
we apply it to a Target domain hospital
it actually has a drop in performance
that's too high we don't like that
wouldn't it be nice if we could just
attribute these performance drops to
specific shifts in the distribution
because those are addressable right so
if we were able to decompose this we
could say you know there's different
parts of the the source and target
distribution and maybe I can collect
more data in this Source or only have it
applied to specific populations in the
target
uh and so we actually have a new paper
uh where we do this we model shift uh
attribution as a game you assume uh this
is a reasonably large assumption uh but
you can do it in some medical settings
you have to assume that you can specify
a causal graph that is reasonable for
your setting and then you can model
shift attribution as a Cooperative game
where the players are mechanisms of
attribution
um each player contributes to the Target
distribution when it's in a coalition
and uh to a source distribution
otherwise and the attribution mechanism
is actually the sharply value and so
when we do this and run it through a
case study what we get is let's say that
we have a algorithm that's trained to
predict in hospital mortality using
vitals and Labs from hospitals in the
American Midwest large sample and then
the model is deployed in hospitals in
the American South smaller sample and we
notice that there is an increase in the
Briar score so it's more poorly
calibrated uh when we apply it to the
Target if we want to ask why the model
fails we can come up with a causal graph
using the data features we have we can
run our method we can say maybe it's
going to be easiest to focus on the
difference of distribution and age
that's the mechanism of shift I want to
tackle we can look at the difference
between source and Target distributions
of age and say aha what we can do is
collect more data from older people on
the source and we find that when we do
this when we deploy this specific
targeted
data collection mechanism we have much
better performance at the Target site
and it's better there is a lower
distance between source and target
distribution
um performance than if you just did
naive retraining with the source and the
target
so the final thing I wanted to talk
about which is maybe the most outside of
my wheelhouse and maybe many of your
wheelhouses given that this is a machine
learning summer school is
post-deployment considerations because
it's possible none of you really will
work on deployments um but it's the
thing I think you should keep in mind uh
because even if you don't deploy your
model if your code is on GitHub somebody
might so let's think about how we can
ensure models will augment and improve
human health care
um so this is the transcript from a
crisis line call uh this is a reasonably
common thing uh that people volunteer
for in in the United States where for
example you get some training saying
you're going to get texts like this I've
added the highlighting for uh
self-reported race and also for
religious identity normally this is all
just black text and that's what our
participants got and we had people read
through this and we gave them some
training we said you know you have two
options there's no liability risk
because this patient is going to get
help no matter what but if there's a
risk of violence you should call the
police right so just like in the outcome
definition part of the talk we have an
if condition if there's a risk of
violence and a then condition then you
should call the police
okay and then we ask people to make this
decision right so they should always
call for medical help unless there's
this risk of violence and then they
should call the police and so at
Baseline people just saw this and this
task
and then we have one intervention we do
uh where we give them some advice and we
either give them advice from a biased
GPT model that we intentionally biased
it's easy to do so that it always says
there's a risk of violence it always has
y equals one there's a risk of violence
you should call the police
um disproportionately for black and
Muslim subjects and then we had an
unbiased model where we fixed the
probability so it did not
disproportionately say you should call
the police on black and Muslim subjects
okay so treatment number one is whether
you as a volunteer
or if you're not in the control group
that gets no advice treatment number one
is whether you get the biased or
unbiased GPT model giving you advice
treatment number two uh is whether you
get the descriptive or the prescriptive
part of the training right so remember
we said if there's no risk of violence
you should call for medical help if and
only if there's a risk of ions then you
should call the police so in the y
equals one case we could either give
them the descriptive recommendation our
AI systems flag this call for risk of
violence or we could give them the then
condition in this situation our model
thinks you should call for police or
medical help
right
um and so this is the second treatment
so there's two things that are being
randomized here if you're in the study
group not the control group with no
advice you're randomized to either get
the biased or unbiased GPT model and
then to either get the descriptive or
prescriptive recommendations right
um and then you make the same decision
you see the same text everything else is
the same so this is a show of hands who
thinks that the first treatment is
what's going to matter most whether we
gave you the biased or unbiased GPT
model
nobody thinks that uh some people think
that who thinks that treatment number
two whether we give you the if or then
condition is what's going to matter most
a lot of people think that
so what we found is that uh clinicians
actually a really large group of
clinicians uh and non-clinicians are not
more likely to call the police on black
and Muslim subjects at Baseline and
that's important right like when they're
given no advice it's they're not
disproportionately likely to call police
on minorities
however when you give them as you all
guessed the biased prescriptive
recommendations clinicians and
non-clinicians are both much more likely
to call the police on black and Muslim
individuals but shockingly for me but
not for you all who are much more
skeptical and cynical than I am
um the descriptive flags from the biased
models didn't have the same effect and
this allowed the participants to have a
retention of their Regional Affair
decision making
the reason this is shocking to me is
because this is not part of certainly my
training but I would say globally our
training if I tell you to predict a
label it doesn't matter you predicted Y
is equal to one you don't think about
well when you deploy this make sure you
have the if condition not the then
condition or the results will be wild
nobody tells you that
um and I don't think it's a very
commonly thought of issue in deployments
in machine learning that when we are
optimizing for an outcome there's
different ways in which the model could
give its advice and it doesn't matter if
you have exactly the same model tiny
differences in how you present that
advice even to experts in this case will
cause them to follow incorrect prompts
yes
nothing we we didn't even tell them it
was a GPT model we said we are training
an AI system to assist people with
triaging right you are going to test
this for us there will be some advice
you should still follow your training
any other questions clarification
all right so
a final thing that I want to go through
is
um I'm often asked
by by many people
um whether we can just fix these issues
with explanations
um actually I would say maybe half of
the papers that I'm presenting here
today what happened was I gave a
presentation and there was this one
person who was so obnoxious and just
said you can fix that with this you can
fix that with this and then I had this
like villain era rage year where all my
graduate students just wrote papers
denying every claim this person made
um this is one of those papers uh so I
like it a lot uh
so uh if anybody ever asks you can you
fix your model bias with explanations
um the argument is well these models are
very complex and the complexity is part
of the issue
so can we use these post-work
explanation methods in order to make
them safer and this is particularly a
common
um
a common justification in health for for
example for designing a new explanation
method some of these methods are
extremely popular when I checked last
lime had over 8 000 citations so it's
it's a very common thing that happens
you could do uh local or Global
explanation methods but the issue here
is that what is an explanation method an
explanation method is fundamentally a
local or Global linear projection often
into a reduced space right
that's how you get this explainability
facet of um of the method
and maybe that does make it easier to
interpret but the problem is like all
approximations there's going to be some
reduction in quality so our question is
who has the reduction in quality uh so
we measured the fairness of local and
Global explanation methods and we're
going to compare the difference between
average Fidelity across groups and your
worst case Fidelity to the original
model performance and then also the
average absolute difference in Fidelity
across subgroups right so if you have a
model and it performs in certain ways
and then you explain it how much worse
is the explanation for different people
than if you just would have used the
original model
so we're not going to just test this in
the health mimic setting of predicting
ICU mortality which is usually what I do
we also wanted to test this across
different human
um process areas where AI has been
either proposed for or is actively used
for assisting decision making so this
would be in financial markets for adult
income prediction for example to
determine whether you are credit worthy
for a loan this would be for an
educational setting predicting whether
students pass specific exams
um and then in criminal justice already
there are models that are allowed to
predict recidivism risk so that judges
could use it in bail hearings to
determine bail
so these are all settings where you
could have an advice uh giving
AI that is uh deployed within the
setting and then the person making the
decision gets to use that advice and
maybe there's an original model and then
there's also this explained version we
find that the explanation models right
so for both local and Global
explanations
they induced subgroup Fidelity gaps
which should not be shocking right like
who do you think gets approximated into
worse performance
um and we also find that this Gap varies
with the dimension of data
representation in the explanation model
that also makes sense the more you
explain a model right so like the lower
dimensionality you force it to be the
worse the approximation errors get and
it disproportionately affects subgroups
often that are underrepresented in your
data
a final thing that uh is maybe more
related to deployments than the
underlying technology is uh people
really trust things when they're
explained in ways that are
um again very surprising to me
so uh humans there are these fantastic
experiments by uh Dr Ayanna Howard of um
formerly Georgia Tech I don't know if
she's still there uh where she had a
bunch of students in a room like this
and then
um smoke started pouring into the door
and you know fire alarms went off and
then there was this cute little rescue
robot that they had previously seen do a
terrible job at navigation come into the
room and say you know follow me to
safety and then people follow this robot
past the clearly marked exit that looks
safe towards a room that looks like
there is no exit and the fire might
actually be coming from it
truly wild uh so you know this this has
already been established in robotic uh
uh settings roboticists that look at
human computer interaction have already
established that uh people can over rely
on robotic systems specifically in two
settings where they believe a robot can
perform a function that it can't right
um or when the person expects that the
system mitigates risk it has some
Fail-Safe it's going to mitigate like
crazy risks uh and those are both true
in health I would argue
um another thing that is uh really fun
is um the fake group at Microsoft
research this is Hannah Wallach Jen
Wortman Vaughn and team
um they did this really fun experiment
where they took people in New York where
um housing prices uh you know fluctuate
quite a bit and so most New Yorkers are
very aware of like what what a place
would go for right so they surveyed
people about uh you know what do you
think this uh this unit would go for and
then they intentionally added um and
then they had a machine learning model
give its prediction of what it would go
for they had both a black box model and
one that explained its prediction by
taking bedrooms times something plus
bathrooms times something and gave you a
market prediction and they had some
intentionally misconfigured units so
instead of a three bed one bath it was a
three bath one bed uh which you would
imagine would not go for very much and
so people predicted that at Baseline
when you gave them a black box model
that predicted that this three bathroom
one bedroom would go for a very high
price they said well the model is wrong
obviously and uh we're not fooled by it
but when you explained it with a formula
well I just took this times this they
said oh no sounds good then they they
took the higher market value
um and so you know we over trust things
that we think we can see a mechanism for
in general it's a human thing it's not
ai's fault it's how we behave and the
final thing is medicine has a lot of
black boxes that we use because we don't
know exactly how it works we do not know
how acetaminophen Works think of that
the next time you take it actually we
don't know how lithium works and I
guarantee you most doctors who prescribe
an MRI do not know exactly how the MRI
machine works we trust that there is a
system that vetted how these things
should be used we trust that there are
audits that the MRI machine is serviced
on a regular contract we trust a system
of Regulation around it even if we don't
understand exactly how a thing works
and so if we need to trust a system of
Regulation around something how do we
get there and the analogy that I'm going
to make here is to Aviation uh where it
used to be very unsafe to fly I didn't
know this but there's a uh Aviation
person at MIT who was telling you the
history and I'm very thankful I Live Now
um so aviation in the United States has
a lot of very formal feedback loops in
the federal government so lots of
different agencies work together to
enhance reporting evaluation and
auditing of different mechanisms there's
a culture of safety so there's a federal
agency that actually has open safety
investigations where they assume there's
no blame assigned until there's a full
investigation and then they try to do
Fair liability attribution and there's a
lot of training and this is completely
absent in health care which is something
that I think is is really frightening
Pilots undergo really extensive training
like thousands of hours in simulation so
they know how to interact with these
automated systems that give them prompts
at different times we need to do the
same thing in healthcare so we can
mitigate some of these automation biases
with training that includes tools
there's many ways you could think about
mapping this Aviation model into at
least the American governments
um the FDA on our side could mandate
audits we have the FTC and arhq that
could monitor what's happening within
different parts of deployments there
could be our page that provides open
data banks of Representative groups so
you can train and audit your own models
CMS could do regulation and
accreditation you don't get reimbursed
by the government unless you've been
accredited for performing at a certain
rate
um and uh at least
hypothetically on our site HHS could do
enforcement so if we find that your
models are underperforming in a deployed
setting then we're going to enforce the
legal code against you
there are some problems hopefully I have
convinced you that are unique to help
that we can't just map over and these
are things that are fundamentally
inequities and underlying data and
processes and we don't want them to be
learned and automated we were asked by a
reviewer what could those possibly be so
here are some examples
yeah I you know everybody has that
reviewer too right
um so as an example gender concordance
being the same gender as your provider
increases the patient's probability of
heart attack survival and this effect is
driven only by increased mortality when
male Physicians treat female patients
that's not my favorite quote from that
paper actually that's in the precedings
of the National Academy of Sciences my
favorite quote is when male clinicians
have more female colleagues they train
with they kill fewer female patients
which is like are we like that's a great
dose response does that mean you should
just be surrounded by women more like I
don't it's it's an interesting effect
uh so this would be like if male Pilots
crashed more when they were flying with
female passengers which doesn't happen
to my knowledge
um the second thing is we know that
patient race uh patient physician race
match improves a lot of quality of life
outcomes and just adherence outcomes
um and these are things that are really
important to longer term safety and
knowledge about your condition so it'd
be like if black passengers only got the
in-flight safety announcement if there
were a black Pilot Flying which I again
do not think happens to my knowledge uh
and the final thing is uh a majority of
Muslim women report experiencing poor
quality care and maternity services with
indicated stereotypical and
discriminatory Behavior as somebody with
three kids I can say that this is true
I've experienced it personally but also
this would be like if there were Muslim
travel bans and Muslim passengers were
always randomly screamed this is true I
was randomly screened on the way here
for the hundredth time so you know there
are lots of things that happen in health
that you would not want to be replicated
in an aviation setting right once we
have these sort of regulatory bodies
that are involved uh there are no simple
fixes for AI and health as I said this
is going to be an ongoing process for
diverse teams and data but if we
consider sources of bias in the data
when we select our problems and collect
our data if we evaluate models
comprehensively when we think about
outcome definitions and develop our
algorithms and if we recognize not all
gaps can be corrected but when you
deploy a model it can still be useful if
you're careful about how the model's
advice is given then I think we can
actually work uh towards better outcomes
this is work done by a really fantastic
group of students clinical and Technical
collaborators and really generous
funding sources
um and I do think that if we learn
robust models audit diverse data and
deploy for advice we can create
actionable insights in human health
thank you